In the bottom half,
the pink babes have taken the field.
He's hit the ball!
Out!
You've got to be kidding!
Hey! That chick took something out of
her wing and threw them at that guy!
What?
-What about it?
-Who do you think you are?
There's always some ugly prig
prattling about right and wrong!
What a priggish mouth!
What?
Well, if it isn't Ms. Tanuki.
Fancy meeting you here.
I'm a mink! I'm not a weasel.
I'm Marie the mink.
I haven't said anything.
-So who are you betting on?
-Bet?
As usual, you don't have a clue.
Baseball in Anima-City
is a total gambling deathmatch.
What?
It's beastman nature to want to win
even if you have to kill.
The flashier the kills, the happier
the fans are. That's what they bet on.
Win or lose. Live or die.
That's Anima-City baseball.
You must be kidding.
Okay! The babes are up to bat.
With her flamingo swing,
she hits the ball!
It happens to...
smash the pitcher!
It hammered Bears' pitcher, Winnie Poo.
Poo's getting carried off on a stretcher.
Oh, dear.
Without a pitcher, you're done for.
There are only nine members on their team.
It looks like we won.
Coach.
Coach!
That's a hole in one!
That girl is our new pitcher.
What? Me?
-No way! Impossible!
-You'll be fine. Just fine.
Back her up, guys!
Okay!
Bears have a new pitcher.
She's clearly an amateur tanuki girl
they've forced onto the field.
-What do they want me to do?
-They're clearly shorthanded.
Hey, ugly! I'm talking to you, ugly!
Hurry it up, ugly!
You're ugly and you are a tanuki.
That's so pitiful, I want to cry.
But I've got a nail appointment later,
so I've got no time for sympathy!
If you're not going to pitch,
then go back home and build a mud boat!
You're the ones who are so disgusting
that it looks pitiful.
What?
How dare you mock the way people look
because they're born that way?
Moreover, you pigeonhole them
to make yourselves feel superior!
That's a sexy strike!
You've got to be kidding me!
That's an unbelievably brilliant
miracle pitch!
No way!
It's the bottom of the ninth.
With the bases loaded,
Bears have a chance to win this!
The batter is the tanuki
miracle-pitch girl!
I've got to build a mud boat later,
so can you hurry this up?
Why, you!
She's hit it!
It's gone!
It's out of the park! I'm dumbfounded!
It's a come-from-behind win for Bears!